blast light is the world's smallest
and most convenient uvc disinfection
light to help keep you safe
against covid19 i take mine everywhere i
go
go to davidpakman.com light to get it
for
forty percent off the link is down below
well we suspected it might happen
because of the increasingly uncontrolled
spread of the delta variant and the
resurgence in covid 19 cases
and it is happening the cdc coming out
with new mass guidelines yesterday
we are going backwards the masks are
going back on
in many many places and seemingly
overnight i'm already seeing more masks
just walking around and yes
this is even for vaccinated
people we're going to look at the new
guidelines
and i am going to sort of couch it all
in saying
um the situation has not really
changed that dramatically for vaccinated
people
although it has changed and it's
important to understand the ways in
which it has
but this is continuing to increasingly
be
a virus that is being spread by
unvaccinated people
which is disproportionately seriously
affecting unvaccinated people
uh and that for now appears to be the
way it is going to continue but that
doesn't mean given what's going on
that vaccinated people shouldn't take
precautions in certain places so
let's look at the new cdc guidelines
updated
yesterday when you've been fully
vaccinated
okay if you are fully vaccinated you can
participate in many of the activities
that you did before the pandemic
to that maximize protection from the
delta variant and prevent possibly
spreading it to others
wear a mask indoors in public if you are
in an
area of substantial or high transmission
that is a major change whereas before
the position was
if you're vaccinated you don't really
need to wear a mask anywhere
the new guidelines are if you're
vaccinated
but you're indoors in public meaning not
with five other people whose vaccination
status you know but if you're in public
indoors
and in an area of high transmission um
which you can look at at a county by
county level
substantial or high transmission the new
recommendation
is to wear a mask for me what does that
mean well that means
when i go to the grocery store the mask
is going back on
um it goes on to say the new guidelines
wearing a mask is most important if you
have a weakened immune system or if
because of your age or an underlying
medical condition
you are at increased risk for severe
disease or if someone in your household
has a weakened immune system
is at increased risk for severe disease
or is unvaccinated if this applies to
you
or your household you might choose to
wear a mask regardless of the level of
transmission
in your area you should continue to wear
a mask where
required by laws rules regulations or
local
guidance so this is
a significant change and we are seeing
the spike i mean if you look at the us
case numbers you will see
that starting oh i don't know right
around june 22nd about about a month ago
after getting down below 10
000 cases per day cases started to go up
up up
including even some 65 000 uh case days
now up to an average of about 57
000 cases per day now what's the hope
here
the hope is that much like we are
starting to see
in some other countries for example if
you look at the uk
which was essentially one of the hubs of
the delta variant
we have already apparently hit the peak
of cases in the uk
that the peak in the uk of delta
seems to have happened around july 22nd
and they are now down from about 46 000
cases a day
to about 32 000 that's a significant
reduction the hope is
that what is now a sort of leveling out
as you can see
over the last few days the cases aren't
continuing to increase in the us they're
sort of
flattening out the hope would be we are
now going to be
uh on the decline but we don't know if
we are and
part of that depends of course on taking
precautions
so let's not go crazy one way or the
other
i think there's a lot of hyperbole on
both sides here and i'm not
playing a both sides game the people
responsible for this
are overwhelmingly the unvaccinated
people and the people taking no
precautions
but the reactions have been sort of
extreme on both sides there's one side
that two months ago said the pandemic is
over
many of these people were never wearing
masks many of these people are still not
vaccinated and they're going back and
and to quote dr anthony fauci letting it
rip
that's an extreme reaction on one side
because it's clearly not over
on the other side are the people who are
seeing this and now saying
we are back to the pre-vaccine
uncontrolled spread
era the truth is that for the delta
variant
if you're vaccinated you're very well
protected
and that protection is bolstered by
people around you being vaccinated now
just like with the flu there are people
who are
vaccinated um who will
who are otherwise mostly healthy who
will get what's called the breakthrough
case
and they will end up hospitalized and a
few of them are going to die
and that's a terrible and tragic thing
but it's important to remember that that
also happens with the flu
and we that doesn't mean we ignore this
fact
but it also doesn't mean that we all of
a sudden believe there's no protection
and we're going back to the
pre-vaccine-covered era the truth is
that
for the most part you are quite well
protected if you were vaccinated you
were
really unlikely to get very sick you
were really unlikely to die however
you could spread it you could spread it
to someone who is in a more compromised
position
and although that's the situation with
the delta variant
the more people remain unvaccinated and
the more the spread continues
the next variant could be more deadly
the next variant could be even more
transmissible and as we've said before
imagine if this had an
8 mortality rate or a 10 mortality rate
if
i don't know that people are looking to
read about this type of stuff right now
that this i don't know people are
looking for this type of fiction
but i recently read lawrence wright's uh
pandemic novel
um i believe it's called the end of
october where
it's a very similar situation to the one
we have except it's like a 10
death rate instead of a 0.8 death rate
or whatever we believe the the real
infection fatality rate to be that is a
dramatically different situation
the more we don't get vaccinated and the
more this continues to spread
it increases the chances of such a
variant developing in the future so
these are the rules at this point in
time
um people asking me if i'm if i'm
canceling my upcoming travel
i'm not and the reason i'm not is this
situation
of different pops and spreads
particularly among the unvaccinated is
likely to continue for a couple of years
and so if i'm not willing to travel now
i probably would shouldn't travel for
years
and i've made the decision in speaking
with friends who are doctors and
others that right now based on when i
got vaccinated and based on this
particular variant
and based on the fact that i'll be
wearing a mask everywhere that it's
recommended i don't see a particular
reason to cancel that trip now
um but a lot of the questions are where
are you going and
and what is your health status etc one
example
we're talking on the bonus show today
nevada or nevada
is going fully masked back on and people
are being advised to avoid las vegas the
level of uncontrolled spread in las
vegas is so high the case positivity
rate is so high
that that's a point where people are
being told just don't go there
uh and i don't plan to so that's uh
that's the situation there
i want to talk about two things we've
talked about many times before but not
together
and those two topics are on the one hand
anti-and pseudo-intellectualism and on
the other hand the kovid 19 pandemic now
covet of course we've talked about
for a year and a half every week and
sometimes even more often we've tracked
cases we've tracked deaths
variants masks vaccines and everything
in between
we've also talked about
anti-intellectual and
pseudo-intellectual movements and that's
a really big topic and this goes back to
the genesis of
american intellectualism in the 1800s or
even arguably earlier than that but it
also includes simply an analysis of
people who read books by by authors like
tucker carlson and bill o'reilly
and they start to think that they're
educated and they have a well-rounded
and
nuanced and detailed view of how the
world works and
the belief that one is much more
informed than they actually are but
these two issues
anti-intellectualism and covid are very
much linked
there's a really good study in nature
that was published a few months ago
called anti-intellectualism and the mass
public's response
to the covid19 pandemic and when i was
looking through this recently i realized
that many of our previous discussions
about anti-intellectualism
apply perfectly to what's been going on
with this pandemic in the united states
it applies to mask wearing
it applies to anti-vaccine sentiment and
to so much more
and the article does a number of
different things to assess how people
came to believe incorrect things
about the pandemic be it about the virus
itself or about public health measures
or vaccines or whatever else
and the conclusion is not going to be a
surprise the article finds quote
we provide evidence of a consistent
connection
between anti-intellectualism and covid19
risk perceptions
social distancing mask usage
misperceptions and
information acquisition very very much
uh
not unsurprising finding so there are
actually two
sides to the people that still won't get
max
vaccinated that still think masks don't
do anything
who think the virus is fake or whatever
part of it
is that they are part of a political
movement whose leaders spent
basically all of 2020 telling them this
isn't very serious
we don't need to do anything open
everything the economy is what matters
most
that's part of it which is politics
plain and simple
but the side we haven't talked about as
much as the anti-intellectualism
a distrust of scientists and doctors a
distrust of authority
feeling that they know more much like
trump always felt that he knew more than
his generals or doctors or whoever
because they read whatever it was on
facebook or because their uncle told
them whatever it was
now you might say well that
anti-intellectual view
is based on their politics so it really
is still politics and i would agree with
you but these are still
two distinct but related phenomena and
then the last piece of this that i want
to discuss
is that the anti-intellectualism and the
rejection of science
is very post-modern which these
right-wingers claim to be against
now of course most of the right-wingers
who talk about post-modernism
don't have an iota of a clue not even a
scintilla of an idea
of what post-modernism is but to the
extent that they sort of understand
it right wingers claim to hate
the postmodern idea that they say exists
on the left
that every narrative is equally valid
every opinion must be given
the same consideration as every other
and i'll tell you what i'm also against
that i've talked about
my opposition to that idea that every
narrative every idea must be given equal
consideration
but those very same people are furious
that their anti-vaccine misperceptions
that their covet conspiracy delusions
aren't being given the same weight the
same consideration
the same seat at the table as what
medical doctors
and public health officials and science
says
it's truly the height of hypocrisy so we
have
yes we have a political movement that
spent all of last year saying you don't
really need to worry about this and
that's a big factor
and then yes we also have this
anti-intellectual pseudo-intellectual
component of people who
because they looked at facebook think
that they know as much as or more than
the public health officials but then the
third layer on top of it
is the incredible hypocrisy of being
against
the culture they believe exists on the
left and it exists in some enclaves of
the left although i don't think it's
predominant
that every idea must be given an equal
seat at the table but that's exactly
what they want and what they expect
with their ideas about vaccines and
masks and whatever else and they become
furious
when social media platforms or
elected officials or whoever say hey you
know what what you're saying just isn't
based in science so we don't need to
give it equal consideration it's
hypocrisy
anti and pseudo intellectualism plus the
politics of the republican party around
the virus in 2020.
let me know what you think and is there
something missing from that
three-layered analysis
i would love to hear from you and uh add
to it in a future segment
we are getting very close my friends to
the 16th anniversary of the david pakman
show august 16th
is that day the 16th anniversary of the
david pakman show to celebrate
we will be doing a one-day membership
special if you've been listening for one
two three four five six sixteen years
and you've occasionally thought i kind
of like this maybe i'll support it
in some way the perfect day to do it
is august 16th if you want to get an
email
telling you how to take advantage of our
16th anniversary discount
just get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors is blast light the
smallest and most
convenient uv disinfection light on the
market
covet is not over there are new variants
there might be future
resurgences so of course it's still
important to take precautions keep
yourself safe keep people around you
safe uvc lights have been proven to
safely and rapidly kill bacteria
mold fungi and viruses including covid19
blastlight is a convenient keychain uvc
light that you can take
wherever you go i keep it attached to my
keys
it goes everywhere with me it's easy to
use it disinfects
any surface in just seconds with a
really long battery life and it's
rechargeable
i've looked at a bunch of different uvc
light options and this
is by far the most compact and portable
one out there
blast light is normally 99 but my
audience can get it for 40 percent off
which comes to 59.50 when you go to
davidpakman.com
blastlight the link is underneath this
video
remember that this program yeah this one
this one today
is mostly made possible by folks like
you who get memberships at
joinpacman.com i
encourage you to grab such a membership
you'll also get instant access
to the daily members only bonus show an
extra show
every single day you know one of the
biggest scams
perpetrated and perpetuated by the
american right
is that they are the patriotic ones they
are the ones who support
the troops they are the ones who support
the police
police they are the ones who are about
america first and as if you needed more
proof that this is an utter
and pathetic lie over the last 24 hours
we have seen
first of all republicans right-wingers
and right-wing media hosts
root literally root against the united
states in the olympics
rooting against the women's soccer team
or rooting
for other countries to win make
fun of gymnast simone biles
for her pulling out of competition
yesterday
the day before yesterday with the time
difference with tokyo i don't know
exactly when it was over the last 24 to
36 hours
making fun of her uh not exactly america
first patriotic behavior
um in terms of how you would uh uh
relate to
or discuss someone who's halfway around
the world representing the united states
in athletic competition and then
yesterday after the first day
of testimony of the house select
committee investigating the january 6
trump riots
after four police officers whose lives
were threatened
as they attempted to defend the capital
on january 6th
widely republicans and right-wing media
hosts
ridiculed the police officers and
laughed at the police officers
and made a mockery of the things that
they said
in their testimony yesterday we're going
to look at some clips
and just remember when you look at this
they say they support police they say
they defend law enforcement
they call themselves patriotic here is
tucker carlson
literally chuckling at the things we
heard
from one of the officers officer fanon
yesterday
look at this people he doesn't agree
with in washington
and that is unacceptable and it should
make you very nervous
watch fanon cite the psychological
trauma he endured
as an excuse for ditching our bill of
rights yeah
i've been left with the psychological
trauma and the emotional anxiety of
having survived
such a horrific event
a very dismissive chuckle from tucker
carlson
this guy we're supposed to believe he's
a patriot and that he supports the
troops and he supports police
except when he doesn't because it's just
really not convenient
it's really not convenient because if
you say wow we should listen to the
testimony of these officers
it uh implies some really horrible
things
about the people who participated in
those trump riots next
here is a clip from newsmax this is host
grant stinkfield grant uh
has never been a law enforcement officer
didn't serve in the military
but he refers to republican congressman
adam kinzinger
who is a veteran as a pansy and then he
mocks another capitol police officer
when the police officer told us that he
thought he was actually going
to die on january 6th uh let's look at
the next clip
and later on from other law enforcement
agencies
i'm afraid to think what could have
happened on january 6.
so grant that's a pretty good question
do you expect that this will answer that
question or pursue it further
no i love that he's reading the
statement i think the statement may have
actually backfired on him because you
know the leader of the capitol police
really is nancy pelosi by the way what
does it mean i love that he's reading
the statement
is that like a dig at that officer is
from the dominican republic
is it a dig at the guy's english
language proficiency i don't even know
what it means
that he says i love that he's reading it
like oh if he wasn't reading it he
wouldn't be able to speak i don't even
understand what that means
so you've got to ask nancy pelosi about
why they didn't have the backup they
so-called needed but you know heather as
i watched this hearing
they told us it wasn't going to be
political and then i got this pansy of a
congressman adam kinzinger
crying as if uh he can't hold it
together here
it's nonsensical it's about the most
political thing i've ever seen
it is all theater typical to democratic
fashion
it is all based in emotion i'm having a
real hard time
believing a lot of what i'm hearing
because the video doesn't back
up nearly all of it one officer said he
thought it was gonna be the moment he
died
well there were no guns at this place
i've watched guns at black lives matter
protests and riots i've watched bricks
being thrown at
officers during black lives now this was
addressed extensively
and there was not only a very long list
of weapons
described by the officers but also
officers described the the belief that
there there were firearms there um
although we should be glad
that the protesters didn't start
shooting that's something to be happy
about not indignant about
as matter antifa riots i didn't see any
of that during this so
this is going to be a partisan event
brace yourselves
i refuse to lead my show with it tonight
we will most certainly talk about it
but there's no way i am giving this sham
of a hearing
uh the do of being at the top of my
program
yeah so stinkfield will be talking about
it but he is not going to lead the show
with it
very principled and defiant uh a dis
production decision there by by
grant stingfield uh not very deferential
to police
not back the blue not the thin blue line
it's none of that stuff all of a sudden
because they only care about that when
it's convenient
here's republican congressman jim banks
this is one of the guys that nancy
pelosi said no you're not going to be on
this panel
he is blaming the police for what
happened on january 6
wow today was the first day again
tragic stories from capitol police
officers experiences that never should
have happened
right if the leadership of the capitol
police and those who oversaw the capitol
police would have done their job leading
up to january 6
we would have trained the capitol police
officers so what happened to the police
on january 6
is the fault of the police because of
what they didn't do
leading up to january 6th i see it's
the the fact that trump incited a riot
and then they rioted and they
beat police officers with flagpoles and
bear spray and all this different stuff
it's the fault of the police guys
remember this guy supports the police
he's he's all very much pro law
enforcement would have given them better
equipment
we would have we would have warned them
about the intelligence report and i
believe that
january 6 would have been a lot
different if the capitol police
leadership would have done their job
if there would have been true leadership
at the top and oversight that didn't
happen
and why are those questions not allowed
to be asked
on this committee what is the speaker
trying to hide by not allowing me and
jim jordan in the room to ask questions
about exactly well jim jordan we're
going to talk about a little bit later
but it's it's becoming increasingly
clear that jim jordan has no place on
that committee because he's an
accomplice
he can't possibly investigate it because
he appears to have been an accomplice
and we'll get to that a little bit later
jim banks of course also voted not to
certify the election
uh part of perpetuating the big lie
these people are truly disgusting and
then lastly here is laura ingram from
fox news
she actually had the gall to call
the um testimony from the officers
performances and ridiculed them by
giving out performance
awards take a look at this i want you to
get to the bottom of that
we have more on him in a moment but it's
not about politics at all
and for best performance in an action
role the winner is
michael fanon too many are now telling
me that hell doesn't exist
or that hell actually wasn't that bad
the indifference shown to my colleagues
is disgraceful all right so laura ingram
making a mockery of the entire thing
and this is the movement that claims
they support police
this is the movement that claims that
they are the defenders of law
enforcement
but that's only when it's convenient to
them these people are
really disgusting we have some very
interesting political election news
in the texas sixth congressional
district republican primary this is two
republicans running against each other
the trump endorsed candidate lost and it
wasn't a huge blowout but it was a loss
and this is our first signal about 2022
which is going to serve to inform what
happens in 2024
from the standpoint of the republican
presidential candidate and whether that
will be
donald trump remember that we are
working backwards now in 2024
republicans will need
some candidate to uh run for president
the question is is that going to be
donald trump well trump running in 24
will be informed by
how do the trump-backed candidates do in
november of 2022
how do republicans do in november of
2022 in the house and the senate
well to get to that you have to start
looking at some of the primaries that
are taking place
right now and in this uh texas sixth
congressional district
so far donald trump has one loss
in that texas uh congressional district
jake elsie the non-trump republican
has defeated the trump-backed rival
susan wright so chalk this up as a loss
for donald trump let's take a look
republican jake elsie of texas
won a house seat on tuesday night over a
rival backed by donald trump
dealing the former president a defeat in
a test of his endorsement power since
leaving office
elsie's come from behind victory over
republican susan wright the widow of the
late rep
ron wright is a special congressional
election runoff near dallas
is likely to be celebrated by trump
antagonists
who have warned against his continued
hold on the republican party
elsie was carrying more than 53 percent
of the vote in texas's sixth
congressional district with results from
almost all precincts reported
one of the things we've seen from this
campaign is a positive outlook
a reagan republican outlook for the
future of our country
is what the people of the sixth district
really really want elsie said to
supporters
the runoff election came down to the two
republicans in a race to succeed
congressman ron wright
who in february became the first member
of congress to die
after being diagnosed with covet 19.
susan wright a republican party activist
and widow of the late congressman
carried the endorsement of trump into
the special election
runoff a few differences in policy
separated the candidates
giving the race in north texas the feel
of a republican
primary far from running on an
anti-trump platform elsie did not try
distancing himself from the twice
impeached former president he instead
sought to overcome the lack of trump's
backing by raising more money and
showing off endorsements including that
of rick perry
so this is actually a really big deal in
a sense
2024 is now and what i mean by that is
we are getting into although we still
have a little while this was a special
runoff
we still have some months until they
really get going but we're starting to
get into primaries for 2022
which are going to determine what
happens in november of 2022
which will determine what happens in
2024 and donald trump
already backing some primary candidates
and the first one here has lost this was
the trump candidate and they did not win
so this is you know it's a sample size
of one we still don't know
what it portends for the bigger idea of
donald trump being a kin
king maker in 2022 uh but this is
already an interesting sign
and uh when i was interviewed by uh
trump's former lawyer
michael cohen a couple of weeks ago
cohen said he doesn't think trump is
ultimately going to run
and the reason trump won't run is it's
going to be clear to trump that he's not
going to win
if he runs in 2024 that's michael
cohen's perspective
um he may well be right he's been right
about many things and he's been you know
not right about some things um if indeed
trump is going to be convinced that he's
not going to win
part of it will be that the people he
chooses the people he backs
for 2022 uh lose and that is at least
what we saw
in the texas sixth congressional
district we'll have more coverage of
that race and others that are upcoming
on the david pakman show instagram which
you can find at david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show
the regular show with no commercials you
also get access to our entire archive
of every episode dating back a really
long time
and plenty of other awesome membership
perks go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount join pacman.com
all right i want to sort of just close
the loop on a couple
of stories that we've been talking about
um the ceo of
my pillow mike lindell who became a
trump friend
early during the pandemic and said trump
was a gift from god
and we thought that's probably as crazy
as this guy's going to get and then of
course
it got crazier and crazier mike lindell
who claims that he has
voting machines in his possession that
same mike lindell
he is now sort of reversing the burden
of proof
after saying he is going to be able to
prove that the election was actually
stolen by joe biden now he's reversing
it and saying
he will give you five million dollars if
you can prove to him
that the election wasn't stolen
wasn't stolen by joe biden which is of
course a very very different
situation a business insider reporting
mike lindell is offering five million
dollars to anyone who can disprove his
allegations of voter fraud
if they show up to his cyber symposium
um he's going to be doing the symposium
in august
mike lindell a staunch ally of trump
leading promoter of voter fraud
conspiracy theories
says he'd give five million dollars to
anyone
who can disprove data that
he claims shows election interference
but there's a catch
to be eligible you have to attend his
upcoming cyber symposium
which is taking place in south dakota
between august 10 and 12.
so there's five million available guys
but you've got to go to south dakota
and deal with mike lindell and people
who support him for three days
uh and the event isn't open to the
public according to an ad for the event
posted on lindell's website frank
invitees include politicians cyber
security experts and the media
though it will also be streamed for 72
hours
on frank lindell said he wants the
symposium
to be the most watched live event in
history
and is aiming for a billion people to
watch via his website
i can't imagine a billion people are
gonna watch this
um he has reserved 800 rooms but few
officials said they would attend there's
also a really there's a funny other
thing to this which is he wants media to
attend
but like normal reporters they can't
take a free room from him they need to
reserve their own rooms to maintain
independence and it's just standard
protocol
so there's actually reporters who have
said in theory i would go to this thing
but because he reserved all of the rooms
i can't take a free room from mike
lindell because then my reporting could
potentially have been influenced by the
fact that i got a free room i'd have to
say i got a free room etc
so he's almost shooting himself in the
foot okay here is
um a clip where mike lindell talks about
the five million dollars
today i'm putting out five million
dollars
to any attendee that comes to this
that's episode that's invited to the
symposium
if they can prove the data is not the
2020
2020 election did you just say 5 million
did you just say 5 million
that's correct yeah so just you know the
concept of burden of proof
it's shifting from i have proof that
something happened
to you prove to me that it didn't happen
as many of you know when we've talked
about burden of proof and logical
fallacies
proving a negative can be very very
difficult and in fact many conspiracy
theories are based on the fact that they
put others in a position of having to
prove that x did not happen
whereas really if they are the ones
making the claim they should be able to
bring us evidence that x
did happen one other really funny thing
and there's a visual component here
which if you're not watching
you're not you're not going to fully
appreciate
there was this exclusive appearance that
mike lindell
did i guess on his own show where
he revealed the packet captures which
prove
the election was stolen what you're
going to see
is there it looks like the matrix it's
just long numbers
scrolling up the screen it's of no
meaning whatsoever there's no column
headings
take a look at this uh and i'll describe
it if you're just listening today
this is this is yeah this is big news
you know this big news why don't you
pull i want you to put the
once again that we're announcing put
those back put those uh the data back up
there again or let it roll again hold
that yeah right
again it's rolling it's rolling right i
really want everybody to know
that that this is you know that this is
what the cyber guys are going to see
this is the real deal here everybody
this is
the first time well tonight we had a
show earlier but today
what's the date today brandon today is
uh july 22nd
thursday july 22nd thursday july 22nd
okay so all that's happening is
numbers are scrolling up the screen like
crazy
and this is supposed to prove that
joe biden didn't really win the election
and as if we need to take this seriously
but some cyber security people looked at
it and again it's like you don't really
need cyber security people to look at it
but
there's no column headings you can't
match these numbers to anything in
particular
they're not evidence of voter fraud of
any kind never mind fraud
that suggests it was actually donald
trump who won even a single state that
he lost
like it just doesn't make any sense
whatsoever so anyway if you want to go
to south dakota between august 10 and
12th and i guess pay to go i don't know
if you have to pay to go or not
um to this symposium and then you can
prove that joe biden won
or that there wasn't fraud i guess
better said there's five million bucks
in it for you okay as many of you know i
am not a christian
i truly don't understand that much about
christianity but
i do feel like i have a sense of crazy
when i see it
and today i have video for you of pastor
dan
bregoin from california playing with dog
poop
shoving his hands into dog poop during a
sermon to i guess make some kind of
point about sin
or something like that now i want to
warn people if you're having breakfast
if you're having lunch whatever you're
doing there is going to be video here of
the pastor
doing schadological play with dog poop
on stage during a sermon now the con
there isn't there
shockingly there is there is context
here
um which is my discussion yesterday of
the tax exemption that churches receive
in the united states i didn't i
mentioned it offhandedly
but i got a ton of emails from people
talking about david i agree or i
disagree with your your point about
churches and tax exemptions so
warning we are going to look at a video
here in which this guy is playing with
dog poop
check out the build-up to this stun and
importantly consider whether this type
of thing
is what we the taxpayers should be
subsidizing
so that churches can do this and yet not
pay taxes but not pay taxes let's take a
look
so do you know what god equates as sin
in the bible he equates
poop filth whoa
in the bible no this is not a brownie
no this is not snickers bar i own tubal
mastiffs in my life
this is great dane dear god
do you know how what a crappy idea guys
god sees now listen this is important
psalm 141 verse 2 may my
prayer be set before you like what like
incense
may the lifting of my hands be like the
evening sacrifices
your sin god says has hidden my face
from you
so that i will not hear so when you come
in
and you're saying god the gods of my
life
compete with who you are but i'm
declaring that i belong
are you guys understanding how this is
building up to smearing himself with dog
poop because i'm not
you god says this is what i see
whoa really trying to score some brownie
points with god we might say
and what i see comes up like incense
before me
oh my god and what's going on in your
soul i can see in ways nobody
he's playing with it like clay now can
see
and so you know what you say oh god
created me a clean heart and renewing me
a right
spirit and cast me not from thy presence
and
take not thy holy spirit from me and you
got
chunks coming off of your thumb and god
is saying what do you want
do you want me or do you want you do you
want your ways or do you want my ways
because you can't have
what you're getting the weight okay what
a crappy way to make a point don't you
think
so that's that's a church they're tax
exempt
a bregoin quotes psalm 141
i guess it's verse 2 or line 2
about lifting one's hands up to god
i think maybe the point he's trying to
make is that
we are merely dog poop without god or or
something like that
um so what is this desperation
is this mental illness is that what is
it is it grifting of some kind
and at some point if you're spending
your sunday
digging through your own dog's poop on
church in a church on a stage
don't you have to reconsider whether god
has
laid out a good life for you at some
point isn't that a question is this what
god wants you to be doing playing with
poop
on a in a church and um
this is what gets me back again to the
blanket tax exemption for churches
i get it if a church runs a soup kitchen
organize it separately
give them a tax exemption if a church
even runs a school even if it's a
religious education if they're doing
good education otherwise and teaching
real stuff
uh let them organize as a non-profit
educational institution
but we have millions of people who are
lacking health care we have hunger in
the united states we have people without
homes etc
but this guy gets a tax exemption for
scatological games
something is very very wrong and i
remain convinced that the blanket tax
exemption
for churches needs to be done away with
i'm not saying there are
situations i'm not saying there aren't
situations where it makes sense
that a church would be tax exempt but
this stuff has to stop
this stuff absolutely has to stop send
me your thoughts and
um you know just just a crappy story to
go to break on here
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as
two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right i have for you
today some of
the funniest video i've seen come out of
the political world for
at least a day or two no for at least
several months
uh two republican members of congress
matt gates
currently under investigation for a
litany of possible crimes
and marjorie taylor green anti-mask
anti-vaxx
congresswoman who regularly compares
things to the holocaust and then
apologizes for doing it
and then does it again they tried to
hold a press conference now
the press conference was meant to be
think about this
in defense of the january 6th trump
rioters
in defense of the rioters not the police
gates and green who normally claim to be
all about supporting the troops and
supporting the police
gates and green apparently believe that
the defendants
the the accused rioters are being
treated too harshly by our legal system
in terms of their detentions and the
like
this is not an issue they have any other
time except when you have
exclusively trump supporters having been
the alleged uh perpetrators now all of a
sudden they care about the harsh
treatment of these defendants by the
justice system
so they hold this press conference and
imagine
that being your primary concern related
to the january six riots instead of
actually investigating what happened and
who incited it
but that's their position so they try to
hold a press conference
when i say try i say that because it
goes hilariously off the rails
when protesters shut it down with
screaming and whistles
and our friend lauren windsor asking
matt gates on repeat
whether whether he's a pedophile let's
get into the first clip
uh and what the funniest part of this
one is it gets shut down
and louis gomer a wacky republican
congressman he sort of tries to just
keep going but nobody cares once gates
and greens start leaving nobody even
listens to louis take a look at this
it's everything about it is perfect
oh the people of this country the
answers to the question
we need we need a break the left is
interrupting the press conference we
need to end it
thank you for those of you that really
care about it
this is just it's just amazing the
whistler
interrupts the press conference louis
gomer
tries to speak but it's just too late
nobody cares everybody's just leaving
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen what you just saw
here today is again the intolerant left
and that the voice you heard there
is i guess an anchor of some kind for
the youtube channel right side
broadcasting network so
the whistles are just absolutely
fascinating
the entire thing gets shut down here is
um here's another clip of the whistler
really preventing this from even from
even getting going i mean it's really
incredible
so that's actually the whistler in the
yellow shirt if people are watching
right in front of the right side
broadcasting anchor just whistling and
[Music]
whistling
they're hurting you okay no they're not
they're not touching you we've had it on
videos
all right now i'm against uh hearing
loss and doing anything that's going to
force hearing loss
on people of course i think it is
important to remember
that you know part there is an onus on
if you want to hold a press conference
in public
then there's the possibility that
because it's in public people are going
to
show up i think that it starts to get
over the line if you blow the whistle
really loud right in someone's ear i'm
i'm right there on that
uh but um the same way that you are
choosing to
speak in a public place people can
choose to yell
or blow a whistle in a public place as
well um
and then it all i mean just the level of
derailment is crazy let's look at one
more of these clips
it's a weapon now now this there were no
weapons at the
at the january 6th riots but the whistle
is a weapon now
i mean it's actually quite stunning how
much havoc and chaos
one guy with a whistle can actually uh
wreak
at this one event okay so then we get
into the point where
marjorie taylor green and matt gates
they essentially just get
run out and they start literally running
away with security or staffers or
whoever
and then this is where there's another
layer to the memetic aspect of this
matt gates start being at starts to be
asked on repeat
whether he's a pedophile and it turns
out that that's actually lauren windsor
who we we
is a you know no a friend of the show
take a look at this somebody take them
away
off they go you saw what happened here
[Applause]
[Music]
are you [ __ ]
oh my god no obviously
child sex abuse and pedophilia is not
funny the
image of lauren with a huge camp like
who even uses a camera that big anymore
it almost could be a prop and it would
add to the comedic element
chasing gates and saying are you a
pedophile is amazing now we actually
have
lauren's video from undercurrent uh with
a different view on this take a look
are you a pedophile are you okay get out
of here
[Music]
[Applause]
oh man so just absolute and total chaos
and again it all goes back
to um there
the whole point of this press conference
was
that yesterday we had the first day of
testimony in the house select committee
um investigating the january 6 riots
and the reaction from matt gates
and marjorie taylor greene is
whoa they're really not treating the
accused rioters very well in the justice
system and of course you and i
have been talking about the fact that
too often
non-violent defendants are held without
bail
or held with a bail that's too high for
them to make so they're stuck in
pre-trial detention
they can't mount a defense they're
unable to make money they're unable to
parent their kids if they have kids and
it just perpetuates the situation we've
talked about that when it comes to
non-violent
uh defendants they now are all of a
sudden concerned about bail being too
high
or bail being denied to people accused
of actual violence in some of these
cases
and now all of a sudden they care and
they want uh criminal justice reform i
mean it's just
all completely and totally pathetic and
the entire thing getting shut down who
knew that a whistle i mean listen
i remember being eight i remember
wreaking havoc with a whistle
but i was never able to wreak this
amount of of of havoc and it's
absolutely fascinating to see all right
we've got to get to something really
really important this needs to be
i am going to show you a video that
justifies
launching a new investigation into
republican congressman
jim jordan and whether he was an
accomplice in a greater way than we
already knew
to the january 6th riots think back
a week to when nancy pelosi said
jim jordan and jim banks can't be on
this committee
investigating the january 6th riots
and at the time i said jim jordan is
more likely a witness
or a co-conspirator than he can really
in any realistic way
be an investigator of what took place on
january 6th
he appeared yesterday on fox news with
brett baer
and brett baer asked him did you speak
to trump on january 6
and jim jordan is caught obviously
trying to obfuscate
you've got to see this let's listen to
it line by line
okay here we go he's obviously going to
go down a number of different roads
about who knew what when who was talking
to coordinators of the protest
did you talk to the former president
that day i've talked to the former
president umpteen times thousands
i mean i may not that okay did you talk
to the president on january 6th
and uh jordan says i've talked to the
president umpteen
times and bret bayer tries to clarify
exactly the date on which he's referring
to
the former president umpteen times
thousands i mean i may not i mean
countless countless times i talk to the
president i never talk about what we
talk about
okay so he's still now he says i talked
to the president
he's still not saying on that day but it
seems to be what he's conceding here
that's appropriate just like i don't
talk about what happens in republican
conferences
so i've talked to the president numerous
times uh i continue to talk to the
president
on january 6 congressman yes i mean i've
talked to the president
i've talked to the president so many i
can't remember so he seems to be
realizing
he can't just lie and say no and he
seems to be realizing
bret bayer is going to keep asking the
question so he tries to slide it in and
says
yes meaning yes i did speak to trump on
january 6th but i've talked to him so
many times
i can't even remember all the times i've
talked to him remember all the days i've
talked to him but i've certainly talked
to the president yeah
and and on that day was
can you share any of the insight of what
he was thinking about that day
very clear question what's the relevance
the relevance is
i alone can fix it the book from carol
lennig and philip rucker
says it has multiple sources who say
trump was basically giddy on january 6th
the reason trump didn't send in the
national guard is he loved what was
going on he was giddy
he was absolutely loving it and my guess
is
that when jim jordan spoke to trump
trump expressed being thrilled about
what was going on now what jim jordan
said we don't know
but it's obvious why jim jordan doesn't
want to talk about what that
conversation was like
uh brett the people we need to come
testify are the people who can
testify to the fundamental questions
well one of those people might be jim
jordan
what exactly was trump's mental state
when you spoke to him was he giddy
about the riots why didn't the united
states capital the people's house have
an appropriate
security posture on that day and what
have we done those are the people we
need to hear from
those that's the information and
testimony we need to get
that's what we should focus on but i
don't think that benny thompson the
chairman of this committee said
the question wasn't about benny thompson
you know the question was about
your conversation with trump things on
the table until we raise this issue
about
the speaker's office is the one who
knows what what the security posture and
why it was
the way it was once we raised that
question said well everything's on the
table
okay so he clearly doesn't want to talk
about what he said to donald trump now
what do we know
about jim jordan well we know that uh
jim jordan was part of a meeting
of house republicans that took place in
advance of january 6th about how to
overturn the election we know jim jordan
was there it's been widely reported
we are aware that on december 21st of
2020
marjorie taylor green matt gates jim
jordan
mo brooks and louis gomer really a cast
of characters
were spotted at the white house and the
reports are that they met with donald
trump so
we know jim jordan met with trump about
how to overturn the results in advance
of january 6.
we know that jim jordan voted against
certifying the results
and we now know that jim jordan through
his obfuscation and his distraction
we know that jim jordan also spoke to
donald trump on january 6. we also know
that trump was reportedly giddy on
january 6th about the riots
we also uh know that donald trump was
responsible
for the military not getting to the
capitol
as quickly as they could have on january
6th and here is the slow
drip about the truth of jordan's
potential role on january
6th my guess is that jordan's
fingerprints
are all over the january 6th riots i'm
sure there was lots of locker room talk
about it and the idea i mean imagine
jim jordan tried to argue his way into
being an investigator of the january 6th
riots
good for nancy pelosi for saying you
can't be on the panel
jim and the reality as we now know it
is that this guy is almost certainly a
witness
to the inciting of that in his
conversation with donald trump
and he may even be an accomplice in what
took place on january 6th
unbelievable truly unbelievable
uh we have a voicemail number that
number
is 219 to david p you can call that
number
uh absolutely any time you want you cut
you want to call it
4am like many people do go ahead here is
a voicemail just reminding us you know
this question of do trump supporters
believe the stuff that's being said
about the election
uh or not and seinfeld is instructive
in listening yeah take a listen to this
david i wanted
by the way a classic is the caller
doesn't
pause the show they call while my voice
is playing in the background that's
going on here well that
as we've all learned from our friend
george costanza right that it's not a
lie
if you believe it and uh
i'm hearing you struggle right now on
your broadcast yeah
whether a spokesperson for trump
is uh able to discern the truth from uh
ablution thank you bye yes i i mean i
think
it's just a line from seinfeld but i
think it actually is instructive it's
not a lie if you believe it and many of
these people
uh certainly have drank the kool-aid
and that's an appropriate term giving
given the cult-like nature of uh
trumpian uh followers and acolytes we
have a great bonus show for you today
now we are going to talk about walmart
offering tuition for employees
is it uh is it a real genuine thing
is it a marketing ploy is it both we
will also talk about a federal judge
forcing an accused capital rioter to
unlock
their laptop with facial recognition and
what this means
for the future of such investigations
and full
mandatory masking returning to the state
of nevada
people told to avoid las vegas like the
plague although
i don't even know if like the plague has
the same meaning now since many people
didn't seem that into
avoiding it all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show
don't miss it sign up at joinpacman.com
and we will speak to them
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blastlight is the world's smallest and
most convenient
uvc disinfection light to help keep you
safe
against covid19 i take mine everywhere i
go
go to davidpakman.com blastlight to get
it for 40
off the link is down below